[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright this is cs50 and this is lecture
seven wherein we pick up where we left
off last time and talking more about
Python but this time using Python for
even more powerful purposes and
alliteration I didn't intend until I
just said it there but the goal here
with Python now is to actually use this
language to generate another language in
particular HTML and what we'll do is
start to provide all the more of a
mental model for what you would call
separation of concerns whereby when you
design more complicated web based rather
when you design more complicated
software you tend to try to adopt
certain design patterns so that you're
not just writing everything in one big
file that gets a little confusing
unwieldy to maintain and to add to over
time but you start to separate your
concerns and your functionality and your
features and your collaborators work
into different files and different
methodologies so we'll try to give you
some of these industry standard
approaches today and why they actually
solve problems but of course how did we
get here a few weeks ago we talked about
this thing this virtual envelope that
just represents packets of information
zeros and ones going across the internet
from point A to point B and among the
messages in these envelopes might be for
web requests and we talked about HTTP a
protocol hypertext Transfer Protocol
that just sends message like this inside
of the envelope and this is requesting
of course the default page of a website
as implied by the slash and in many
cases but not always this implies the
default file name of index.html but
that's a human for convention not a
requirement
hopefully the server responds with a
numeric code equal to what integer 200
hopefully a number that we never
actually really see unless you get more
comfortable and start poking around
Chrome's inspector and you look at your
network traffic right so here is an
actual successful response which means
everything is indeed okay and if the
browser looks a little farther down in
the virtual envelope if you will it will
see another language called HTML
hypertext markup language which is the
stuff we wrote a couple of weeks ago and
you'll continue writing this week as you
now dynamically generate websites but
what we'll introduce today is what's
also known as a framework or more
precisely a micro framework
because we'll saved in just a few
minutes time that it can actually be
really annoying and really tedious to
generate websites automatically using
Python if you have to write Python code
alone and so humans over the past
several years have noticed wow every
time I make a web application using
Python
I find myself typing the same lines of
code again and again just to get started
or when I'm collaborating with someone
else I find that whoo it's a little hard
to collaborate if we're all working in
the same file so humans have invented
what are called frameworks and this is
an example of code written in Python but
using a framework called flask
so whereas bootstrap which you played
with a little bit is a framework for CSS
and kind of sorta JavaScript they have
some dynamic features as well a flask is
a framework for Python that just gives
you some library code that you can use
freely in your own applications and it
just makes it ultimately a little easier
to get your work done and build the
thing you want to build as opposed to
having to re-implement
or reinvent the wheel again and again
like people before you and so here is a
methodology to which I alluded earlier
just to have a mental model for the
coming weeks so up until now pretty much
every program we've written in C and
most recently in Python you could call
like controller code or controller logic
or business logic right it's all about
getting something done logically usually
in one file maybe two files if you have
another helpers dot C or header file or
or whatnot but we've been writing logic
but today and two weeks ago when we will
focus on web programming in HTML and CSS
there's this second part of our world
there's like the logic that just gets
the interesting work done with loops and
conditions and all that but there's also
now going to be the aesthetics the stuff
that the user actually sees and the way
you present your data so we're gonna
just introduce two letters of an acronym
today moving forward anytime you start
writing logical code in Python it's
going to be called your controller it's
sort of like the machine that operates
your entire web application but anytime
you do something more aesthetic we're
gonna call that your view code so C and
V being the letters here and this just
refers to like a separation of concerns
your logic goes in this file and your
aesthetics and formatting go in this
other file next week we'll introduce
databases and SQL
structured query language and will
introduce an M here because the acronym
that's invoked for quite some time now
is MVC though there are alternatives to
this mental model and that just means
there are three different types of
things you should be thinking about but
when building an application but today
we're gonna focus on these two
controller and view and up until now
we've pretty much didn't been doing
entirely controller stuff when writing
code so the motivation ultimately will
be to get to the point of building
essentially this the freshman intramural
sports website which I was the first one
to make back in 1996 as a sophomore
maybe 1997 as a junior after having only
taken cs50 and a follow-on class cs50
one and even though this is horrifying
to see now a days underneath the hood
was a whole bunch of controller logic
and a whole bunch of model code even
though I don't think MVC existed as an
acronym back then until humans kind of
figured out the pattern but what it did
have via the menu up here was a whole
lot of functionality so no longer did
you have to walk across campus filling
out a form and drop off a sheet of paper
and like an RA or Proctor's dorm room
you can instead just go on the web which
all of us surely take for granted today
fill out a web-based form and then at
the time the proctor in charge of frosh
IMS would get an email confirming who
had actually registered for sport and
eventually we added CSV files comma
separated value files like spreadsheets
in which the data was saved then we had
this really cool tournament bracket
thing which is all very dynamic and
impressive I'm sure at the time but
we'll focus on really just the
fundamentals today so how do we get
there well let me go ahead and open up
cs50 IDE and propose that if we want to
make a website a web application really
and by application I mean something that
does have logic by website it's
generally something that's static so
that's what a web app is it's something
that changes based on who's using it
when you're using it and what you're
doing with it let me go ahead and in
most the most annoying tedious way
possible implement a web application
using Python so I'm gonna go ahead and
open a file called serve dot tie to
serve up a website and I'm gonna go
ahead and import some library code so
from HTTP server import something called
base HTTP request Handler and also
something called HTTP server and then
I'm going to go ahead and use this new
keyword class which
is HTTP server server request request
handler base HTTP request handler then
handler then I'm going to go ahead and
in here implement a function called do
def do gets which implies this is a
function in Python that should be called
anytime a user visits my web server via
gets the type of verb that we talked
about in the context of the web so
suppose that my only goal here is to
make a web based application that for
the moment just says hello world we know
how to do this with HTML but with HTML
that's just a file let's write a program
that not just prints HT a hello world
but generates a web page containing
hello world so the way I might do this
is this I can literally say self because
self refers to the web server in this
case and I can go ahead and send a
response code of 200 just kind of
presumptuously assuming everything's
gonna be ok in a moment then I'm gonna
go ahead and send a header which recall
we've discussed briefly in the past
whereby this header is gonna be content
type and its value is going to be text
HTML which is a clue to the browser that
it's receiving not a jiff or a JPEG or
something else but an actual HTML page
and then I'm gonna go ahead and say
that's it for the headers I'm gonna call
function called end headers and then
lastly I'm gonna use Python code to
dynamically generate my website now what
is the website have to have just hello
world at the end of the day but there's
a whole bunch of HTML we need to do in
order to get to that point so I'm gonna
use a function called W file right in
order to write out the following let me
go ahead and write out doc type whoops
exclamation point doctype HTML then let
me go ahead and do the same thing W file
that's right let me go ahead and copy
pasted this moving forward which of
course is always a bad instinct then let
me go ahead and output 'html lang equals
en for English and notice I'm using
single quotes inside my double quotes so
that Python doesn't get confused then
let me go ahead and output alright it's
head tag here then what comes after the
head tag typically yes so usually title
lately
so title will be like hello whoops hello
title close the title tag and now we're
gonna go ahead and what comes after
title closed head I think from doing
this right and then after this we
probably have body and then hoe my god
this is the worst way to build a website
but let's go ahead and now say something
simple like hello world and now let's go
in here and say something like body and
then finally let's go ahead and end the
page and say slash HTML done okay and
now I actually need to configure the
server to listen on a port so let me go
ahead and define a tcp port of 8080
which we've been using let me go ahead
and define the server's address as being
o 0 dot 0 dot 0 dot 0 which is what the
IDE uses by default like a lot of
servers and then let me create the web
server HTTP server server underscore
address HTTP server request Handler HTTP
d dot serve forever
ok that is how you make a web based
application that dynamically generates
HTML retrospect I really regret typing
all that out because the whole point now
is to throw this code away like this is
why frameworks exist if my goal quite
simply at hand is to write Python code
that dynamically generates HTML then
calling lots of functions like right
which is essentially the equivalent of
print in this context it's just tedious
I got bored writing it I accomplished so
terribly little at the end of the day
and so frameworks exist to make our
lives easier but what's going on
underneath the hood is exactly this when
we start using this framework called
flask it's just gonna make all of this
automated for us it's going to make it
easier to specify the IP address that
you want to run your web server on it's
going to make it easier to specify the
port number that you want your server to
be listening on and it's gonna make it
easier to respond to get requests
because flask will take care of the
implementation of some function like
this one called do get so all of this is
there underneath the hood but the flat
of the flask framework gives us
essentially an abstraction on top of
that so
do I actually mean by that if we want to
distill this now into a web simpler web
application first let's go ahead and do
this let me go ahead and open up a
terminal window and let me go into my
code here and go ahead and run Python
observe PI and you'll see nothing seems
to be happening just yet so I'm gonna go
to cs50 IDE web server to open up a tab
containing the web server that I'm now
running and you'll see that's it that's
the only thing I accomplished right now
it's not dynamic to be sure but there is
code in Python code there with which I
could actually do something dynamically
but let's instead do this now with flask
this framework that seems to make our
lives easier I'm gonna go ahead and make
a program called application dot Pi
which is just a convention I could call
it anything I want and I'm gonna go
ahead and say the following let's first
go ahead and import this framework
called flask and specifically import
capitalised flask which is the name of
the framework itself and then let me
preemptively import a couple of
functions called render template and
then this special global variable called
request you would only know to do this
from reading the documentation but now
let me go ahead and say hey flask could
you please give me a web application and
this is copy paste you need this at the
top of any flask application and it just
means turn this file application dot PI
into and web application then lastly I'm
gonna go ahead and do this I'm gonna
tell flask I want to build an app that
has a route that's listening for slash
inside of that virtual envelope and
whenever flask you see a request for
slash from some user go ahead and call
this function which I'll arbitrarily
called index but I could call it foo or
bar or whatever and what I want you to
do is this return hello world and that's
it so all of those other lines I
tediously wrote out a moment ago are now
distilled into just seven lines which
none of which are completely obvious how
they work just yet but if you assume
that this means give me access to the
library turn my file into a web
application and listen now for get
requests on slash then it kind of makes
sense and fits into the mental model
that we introduced a couple weeks ago
with HTML and CSS itself and to run this
server what I'm going to go do now in my
hello
directory which is where a online copy
of this is on the courses website I'm
gonna go ahead and quite simply say
flask run so a flask is not only a
framework or code that what you have
access to as free and open source code
but it's also a program you can run at
the command line that also figures out
how to return the server on and just run
it forever you're gonna see some
diagnostic output at first glance most
of which you don't have to care about
but there will be a URL that's a spit
out which is based on your own username
mine today is J Harvard 3 just for
demonstration purposes and if you click
on that URL and then click open you'll
see now this version of the same
application doing just this now I'm kind
of cheating though because if I open up
Chrome and view my page source notice
that of course I'm cheating because all
I've done is print out hello world and
if I view the source of this page I'm
literally only going to see hello world
and no actual HTML because I literally
didn't type out any HTML in my file
but it turns out that flask's makes this
easy as well so let me go ahead and stop
the server here for just a moment ctrl C
is your friend it gets you out of
whatever program is actually running and
let me go ahead and do this let me go
ahead and not just return quote unquote
hello world as a hard-coded value let me
go ahead and return the rendering of a
template called index.html and so this
is a feature of flask 2 if you want to
separate your logic your controller from
your HTML your view you literally put
the former in application dot PI and you
put the latter in an HTML file like this
and you tell the controller code
application PI to show the user to
render for the user the index.html file
so where do I put this the convention
would be to make a directory called
templates and then in that directory go
ahead and put a file called index.html
and if I go ahead and open up the file
that I already created in advance of
class here let me just show you what
this looks like and then we'll take a
look at it in a browser here is HTML now
with a pretty fancy feature that we're
about to reveal the utility of what
jumps out at you as new in this file
yeah
yeah two curly braces and somehow or
other that used to be saying world but
in my final version of this I actually
am hinting at some more powerful
capabilities this kind of looks like a
placeholder if you will maybe someones
actual name and here's where the power
of something like flash comes into play
it makes it really easy to do something
like this so let me go ahead and
actually turn this into something a
little more interesting let me go into
application up high and before I
actually render this HTML file let me go
ahead and do this
let me AHA go ahead and declare a
variable called name and let me go ahead
and check the incoming requests the
inside of that virtual envelope
let me check its arguments or any of the
HTTP parameters that were passed in and
try to get something called name like
this let me go ahead and save that and
then notice this render template takes
multiple arguments the first one should
be the name of the template you want to
render but if you want to pass in data
dynamically you can use named parameters
in Python recall from last week that you
can do things like this x equals y and z
equals W you can pass in the names of
the things you want to pass in and their
corresponding values so if I want to
pass in a name variable and set it equal
to the name variable that I just defined
watch what we can do here let me go back
to my console let me go ahead and rerun
in my hello directory which is available
online flask run and now let me go over
to this where it previously said hello
world let me now just like with our
Google example a couple weeks ago type
in not Q equals cats which is what we
did last time but maybe name equals
David to simulate a get request and if I
did everything right when I hit enter I
now see this dynamically and if I change
this now from David to say Veronica of
course this is going to dynamically
output this can someone now try to break
my code propose an input that I should
try to see if I messed up somewhere
no entry okay no input or what's that I
say again name equals name I like that
one too so let's try that name equals
name so okay I mean it's kind of a lot
maybe like a grammatical bug or semantic
bug but not really a code bug per se
that's just user error but what if I
just get rid of it okay that just looks
a little stupid so an aesthetic bug but
we should probably start handling this
what if I get rid of name altogether
interesting it seems that my final
version actually has some built-in
functionality so where is that coming
from well what if I did this it turns
out that I could say something like this
if not named then go ahead and set name
equal to world would be one way of doing
it or I could actually use the
dysfunction here turns out that this get
function can take a default value and so
if you read the documentation you'll see
that the second value provide will be
used if the user hasn't provided one and
so indeed if I reload now and see
nothing I get world and if I instead do
name equals say Brian I get that dynamic
output and so when I mean when I say web
application this is just a hint of what
I mean this is dynamically generated
content it's not hard-coded because it's
actually coming from the user so when
Google implements its slash search web
application this is the kind of thing
they're doing it's way more involved of
course they're searching a database
looking for cats and dogs or whatever it
is you're searching for and then
generating HTML but notice with just
this simple approach can we ourselves
generate any HTML we want dynamically
because all we have to do in that
template called index dot HTML is
exactly this hello comma and then a
placeholder where name is the variable
you're passing in and so to be clear it
doesn't have to be called name I could
do something like foo which would be a
little nonsensical but if I do that the
variable I plug-in needs to be called
foo here and so there's a one-to-one
correspondence between the things before
the equal signs and where they get
plugged in down here are any questions
then on this simple example but building
block yeah
sure by dynamically generated I mean I
have not written in advance by typing it
out manually a web page that says hello
David or hello Brian
or hello Veronica that page of those
pages are all generated dynamically
based on user input I wrote most of
those pages I wrote everything up into
and after the comma but then I'm sorry
up to the comma but then the names are
dynamically added good question other
questions
all right so why don't we rewind to 1997
or so and see if we can't build a more
dynamic web application that actually
allows students to register for
something that's a little more
compelling than just providing their
name so let me go ahead and open up
frosh I am which is the first
larger-scale
application we have here today and
notice that I have a few files so
already things are going to escalate
quickly whereby we're gonna suddenly
introduce multiple templates but we'll
do this in order to solve a problem but
first let me go ahead and open up
application PI which just like your main
function in C is kind of the entry point
now to a web-based application so notice
that let's start like this let me go
ahead and delete that and start from the
beginning here let's go ahead and do
this in frosh IMG row we have this
default route of slash and notice that
it's going to render index.html so when
you start to read someone else's code
you kind of follow these breadcrumbs so
let me go ahead and open the same folder
frosh I am let me go into let me go
ahead rather let's do this from scratch
actually let's do this index.html and
let me do the familiar doctype HTML then
let me go ahead and do an HTML tag here
it finishes my thought for me the head
tag here the title tag here frosh IMS
will be 0 will be the title here let me
go ahead and create a body and now for
this web page I want to go ahead and
have a few things via which the user can
actually register for frosh I am so let
me go ahead and have just some title
text here like register for frosh IMS
like I did back in the day then let me
go ahead and start a form tag and then
in here what information might
student wanna provide when registering
for something like a sports team okay
the students name so input type equals
text the name of this input probably
shouldn't be something generic like Q it
should probably be more descriptive like
name so it's a little weird looking but
name equals name and we'll go ahead and
do this and if we really want to be
fancy we can do like a placeholder text
of name just to in light gray text show
the user what we want and then back in
the day minimally the students
registering for sports how to provide
their dorm so the building in which they
lived
so in HTML we've got a bunch of input
types we've got text boxes turns out
there's text areas which are even bigger
check boxes radio buttons what's most
apt perhaps for choosing your dorm like
a drop-down list otherwise called a a
menu but which tag I'm sorry not a
container a little more precise than
that what with what tag can you generate
a drop-down list if you've done this
before in HTML select so it's not
perfectly clearly named but it's indeed
a select menu by name and so I can
actually do this select and the name of
this field will be dorm for instance and
then inside of this I'm gonna go ahead
and have a few options so one option
might be lets say a plea court which is
one of the buildings in which freshmen
live there might be another one called
kanaday and then there's going to be
bunches of others and then notice too if
you've never used a select menu which
wouldn't refer Lee had occasion to yet
unless you've done this before these
options also have to have values which
for my purposes are going to be exactly
the same but whereas what's between the
tags is what the human sees it's what's
between these quotes as the value of
value that the computer actually sees so
these are the words that populate the
drop-down menu these are the values that
actually get stuffed into the virtual
envelope that the student him or herself
actually see so let me go ahead and save
this let me go ahead and now open up my
console and I'm gonna borrow a little
code just so that we can do this from
scratch here so let me go ahead and grab
from frosh I am my application dot Pi
file and go into my workspace
so let me go ahead now and run flasks
run wherein I have this application dot
PI file I'm gonna see the URL at which
my code now lives and if I open this up
I'm gonna see an internal server error
so intended at some point because
internal server error recall was one of
the more arcane status codes 500 that
you probably have not seen unless you're
visiting a website where something has
actually gone wrong so how do I begin to
figure out what has gone wrong now that
I'm actually writing code and not just
writing hard-coded HTML well all of the
clues are gonna be found here inside of
the console window so when you're
running flask you are running a
full-fledged webserver you are listening
via tcp/ip for incoming requests from
users and so what you'll see in the
console is not just a diagnostic output
when you first start scratch start flask
but you're gonna see all of the error
messages that might actually happen
thereafter and this is a little cryptic
looking frankly it's overwhelming to see
this text at first glance but whereas in
clang and in C it generally helps to
look at the very top sometimes the error
messages here in this context of flask
you're kind of toward the bottom and
here we have template not found template
because you can't find index.html and
that's just because I screwed up so let
me actually exit flask by typing ctrl C
and if i type LS in my directory notice
that I haven't quite practiced what I've
preached it's perhaps a little subtle
but I haven't organized myself in the
right way what have I done wrong
yeah yeah it's kind of a silly mistake I
didn't make a templates directory so you
can do this in a few different ways by
the folder icon up here you can create a
new folder by right-clicking or
ctrl-clicking or in Linux you can do
make der for make directory and so I can
do make der templates enter and then I
can move my index dot HTML file which I
wrote a moment ago into my templates
directory by just using MV for move and
now I can go ahead and run flask run
cross my fingers go back to the browser
tab and click reload and voila now I
actually see the form so have these
kinds of instincts I didn't actually
intend that but I forgot to create the
folder I got this server error you don't
have to just stare at the browser which
is not gonna have much information but
if you look at the console the terminal
window
that you have control over will you see
those clang like errormsgs so here we
have a basic HTML form it's not complete
because I didn't bother typing out all
of the dorm names but I do have an input
of type text as well as the Select menu
and I'm also kind of missing a key
detail it seems what should I probably
add to this form
yeah well I'm selecting I could be
selecting dorm so I could clean this up
in a couple ways I also am missing a
submit button now it turns out you could
probably hit enter and it would actually
be submitted by default but we can fix
this so let me go into index.html let me
shrink this tab just a little bit and
let me fix both of these things so let
me go ahead and open up this latest
version which is now in that templates
directory let me go ahead and at the
bottom here do an input type equals
submit the value of which is gonna be
say register just to make clear to the
human what's going on let me go ahead
and go back to my form click reload and
nothing's happened just yet and that's
because by default when you make changes
to some of your files flask is not going
to notice and we'll fix this actually in
the coming problem set by adding more
code and a little more complexity to
automate this for you but when in doubt
just ctrl C to quit flask then go ahead
and rerun flask that'll reload all of
your HTML all of your Python code and if
I now go back here and click reload
we'll see the register button so no
there should never be any surprises and
if there are just try to get to the to
the diagnosis thereof
this is also a little unclear to as to
what this menu is so it turns out that
if you actually create a bogus option
like this that has no value and say
something like dorm you can save this
let's go ahead and restart flask and
reload the page here you'll see that now
you see dorm unfortunately this is kind
of stupid because now dorm is where you
can literally live apparently which
doesn't quite feel right
so there's HTML fixes for this too I can
actually go in here and technically say
disabled so you can't actually select
that now if I rerun flask and reload now
it still shows it there but because I
already selected a plea court you can
see it in grey and we can actually be a
little more specific if you want to not
only disable it but select it by default
and then go ahead
and reload the page here now you'll see
hopefully what's familiar on most
websites it says dorm but it's disabled
and even though the silly checkmark is
there like you're forced to choose an
actual dorm so these are minor
aesthetics but the kind of things you
now have control over so what's gonna
happen I haven't actually specified
where this form should go when I
actually register because I'm missing
some key details on the form tag and we
haven't done this in a couple of weeks
but when we were playfully re
implementing Google what else did we add
to the form tag what attributes anyone
remember yeah oh so you again action
which is means what what to do
alright so the action we want to take
even though this is not necessarily
perfectly net well name is where do you
want to submit the form to and I could
actually submit this in a few different
ways I'm gonna go ahead and say you know
what submit it to a a reasonably named
route slash register Google for instance
might have code that instead says to
submit their form to slash search but
we're not searching for something we're
registering so the name of the route is
entirely up to us and via what method
should we submit this information what
are our two options get or post re get
it tends to be the default if you don't
mention in links why much you want to
use post instead yeah you want it to go
to a database and do something in the
right verb to use there is to post
information as opposed to getting
information and even more specifically
when it comes to privacy when you use
post the information doesn't end up in
the users URL and therefore it doesn't
end up in his or her history and
therefore doesn't end up in a place that
siblings or roommates or anyone else can
actually see just by poking around so
we'll go indeed go ahead because this is
my name and dorm and maybe my phone
number and email and credit card number
or the like on some other website I'm
gonna use post for that instead so the
catch here is that this week we now have
the ability to implement slash register
two weeks ago we could just send people
to Google's slash search but now we have
the ability to make our own routes but
how many routes have we defined thus far
in application PI just the one and it's
again some new syntax with the funky at
sign and the route keyword here
but let me actually just intuitively
guess that you know if I go ahead and
say app dot route slash register I bet I
could implement a second route and tell
the web server to listen in two places
on slash as well as on slash register
but if I wanted to listen specifically
on post it actually has to be this
methods equals quote unquote post
because that by default just for
convenience it assumes only gets so I
need to add that you'd only know that
from the documentation now I want to go
ahead and define a function this is
slightly an annoying feature of flask
you have to give the function a name
even though you'll probably never
reference it anywhere so I'm gonna go
ahead and just reasonably call this
register and now I have to do what am I
gonna want to do when the user clicks
that submit button I want to store it
somewhere so I probably want to store it
but what what might I want to do first
before he or she is actually allowed to
register even though they've clicked
that submit form maybe confirm their
information right because if a lazy user
comes in or if a user accidentally
clicks the button or hits enter they
might actually submit nothing no name no
dorm that's not useful information it
could just be perceived as spam so we
probably want to ask some kind of
logical question like if they didn't
give us a name or they didn't give us a
dorm like yell at the user in some way
so I'm gonna go ahead and do that so let
me actually express this in Python kind
of like we did last week with some error
checking so recall that the user's name
can be gotten from an HTTP parameter
from the request dot args get and then
ask for the name parameter their dorm
meanwhile can come from request args get
dorm and again this request args is
something we gave ourselves access to up
here when we said hey flask please give
me access to the users request that
virtual envelope request args refers to
all of the HTTP parameters in the URL
and get it's just a function or a method
built into that special flask feature
that allows us to get a specific
parameter like name or dorm or anything
else and recall that in Python what's
kind of nice is that you can say pretty
English like if not door if not name or
not not dorm let's go ahead and
reprimand the user for instance we could
say failure the
see or she did not actually cooperate as
we intended otherwise if they did
cooperate I'm gonna go ahead and render
template success and we'll flesh this
out in just a moment so I've got two
scenarios handled if they didn't
cooperate or if they did render
quote/unquote failure or a full fledged
HTML template so now that I've
implemented slash register and I'm
listening for a route of via post let's
go ahead and reload the page for good
measure type in my name not gonna tell
you my dorm but you're gonna notice as
much okay so now the server has noticed
that I didn't actually cooperate and
provide both a name and a dorm and so
it's returning to me just quote unquote
failure so that's good because now I
know all right I did something wrong
clearly let me go back let me go ahead
and maybe do candidate here and now let
me go ahead and register but but but but
this I know in advance is gonna error
why I don't have a success dot HTML okay
so let's preemptively address this let
me actually go in here to my templates
directory I'm gonna go ahead and create
a new file called success dot HTML let
me go into the templates to save it
there and you know what success can be
pretty simple page and let me open my
index page let me copy that let me go
into success let me paste this let me
get rid of all of that body and just say
success for instance all right so let me
now go ahead and go restart flask
because I've made a new template let me
go ahead and reload the form just for
good measure let me go ahead and give
you my name this time and okay I live in
Canada and register and what did I do
wrong this time so it turns out you
can't do it this way obviously so when
you're actually submitting information
to a form via form via get flask very
cleverly puts that information in a
different place because by definition as
I claimed very correctly earlier in
request arcs or all of the key value
pairs that are in the URL that are
coming in from the users request but
when you submit by a post for reasons I
wish were now otherwise you actually
have to access those values via a
different variable so instead of using
request args you have to use request dot
form both here and here to make clear
and this is horribly named for exactly
the reasons
I think I'm trippin over here because
they actually are both coming in via
form via get or post but flask puts get
arguments in orgs and poets post
arguments in form thereby leading
clearly to potential confusion but if I
go ahead now and load this version of
the site and I keep keep hoping I'm
gonna go ahead now run flask restart
this page type in David to give you my
dorm and register and successfully
register for frosh I am see how easy web
programming is so hopefully now we can
at least focus on the structure of what
I've done and now begin to improve it
because notice that I kind of did not
practice what I preached a moment ago
what habit did I violate when I whipped
up success HTML how did I get to that
point yeah yeah I copied and pasted
which again usually in programming not
the right thing to do might get the job
done superfast but it's probably the
wrong instinct because it's gonna get
harder and harder to maintain now why is
that you've played with HTML a couple of
weeks ago and recall from that problem
said when you had to make a home page
you probably found yourselves copying
and pasting across your two or three or
four pages because you wanted them to
kind of look the same and therefore it
made sense for them to have some
commonalities but in HTML alone there
was no way to say use the same layout
for my whole site use the same color
scheme the same fonts the same CSS but
just change the body of the page for
each individual page and so some of you
very rightly on discourse and beyond
like posted questions asking could you
do this and you can't really in HTML
alone but now that we have access to
Python an actual programming language
that can do things logically now you can
actually start to factor those things
out too and notice in this file success
HTML as well as in index.html what are
some of the commonalities suffice it to
say the form is only in one of them but
what else is obviously redundant
everywhere the title the head of the
page more generally the doctype at the
very top the body tag alone and you
could imagine there be even more details
like from your own home pages that you
wanted to be the same
multiple pages so let's actually take a
look at a refactor is a ssin of this
code the one I did write in advance in
frosh I am and you'll see why it
actually makes sense to have not only
multiple files each of which represents
one of your routes or your views but
also to have this file called layout
HTML in flask when building a web
application that you know is going to
follow a certain structural pattern
commonalities across all of your pages
you can actually do this so in this file
here layout dot HTML is a whole bunch of
hard-coded HTML and it's pretty simple
it's got my HTML tag head tag title tag
body tag and a few other things but
that's the general structure of the page
and notice it has this funky syntax in
the middle in white here is what's
called a block this is now flask
specific just like flask supports those
two curly braces on the left and the
right that says put a value here flask
also supports this other notation curly
brace percent and percent curly brace
that actually allows you to put
placeholders for actual chunks of HTML
not just variables but actual chunks of
HTML and so this layout you can think of
as a mold or a template literally that
all of your other pages are going to be
structured based on but they are going
to vary in this line and only this line
and we're gonna put as much HTML between
the body tags as we want the open and
the close tag this just indicates the
flask this is the stuff that should be
changing so if I now look at my
index.html which recall earlier
contained my form index.html notice that
here's the form and I finished it
earlier I went ahead and typed out all
of the freshmen dorms not just the two
of them and you'll see that the file
starts almost the same and then
continues with more stuff but notice
what's missing from index.html this time
no doctype no HTML tag no head tag no
title tag no body tag all of the common
stuff has been factored out but there's
some funky new syntax that again is
flask specific this first line is the
link between this file and the layout
that first line says hey flask this
index.html file
extends the definition of layout on HTML
so says grab that template and
plug myself in there what do you want to
plug in the same syntax here when you
actually put stuff between the block tag
and the end block tag which is down
below that's when you say two flasks go
ahead and take this stuff and plug it
into the placeholder in the layout so
meanwhile the success page also now can
be a little more sophisticated if I go
into success it's not very complicated
and honestly it doesn't even look like
HTML anymore because we're using these
more dynamic features but this just says
hey flask use the same layout so the
page is structured exactly the same but
for the body go ahead and plug in this
value instead so indeed when you go
ahead and load this success message you
see this message here not just success i
expound it here and said you are
registered well not really that's cuz
there's no database yet but that's gonna
generate a full-fledged HTML page and
what about failure before I was just
cheating and just saying return failure
quote unquote no HTML at all the failure
page is going to be almost the same but
now I can actually provide some
descriptive text this body just as you
must provide your name and dorm thereby
admonishing the user for not having
cooperated properly so now your home
pages if you kind of extrapolate from
this could have the exact same layout
aesthetics and sort of menu bars and all
of that fanciness but only the content
would have to change and you can get out
of the business of just copying and
pasting so there to your question
earlier about dynamism the dynamism
doesn't have to just come from the user
it can also come from the construction
dynamically of a website based on
multiple pages so at the end of the day
the browser has no idea that Python
exists has nothing to no familiarity
with flask all the browser still sees as
an HTML page
but what flask and intern Python are
doing for us is constructing that page
dynamically following the rules from two
weeks ago on HTML and CSS and following
last week's rules on how Python works
questions yeah
it's not good question the this new
syntax the double curly braces that we
saw earlier and now the curly brace
percent signs this is actually yet
another language called Jinja ji nja
which is a templating language which and
there's dozens of these things in the
world people just come up with their own
syntax and the reason for the funky
syntax is that the author of Jinja
presumably could think of no other
language that uses like a curly brace
and a percent sign and a percent sign
into curly brace and so therefore they
decided you know what I'm gonna use this
syntax because it will look distinct
from HTML and CSS and Python
so that frameworks like flasks don't
confuse it with something else it's
automatically supported so flask by
default supports Jinja it could have
come up with its own templating syntax
but whoever invented flask decided I
don't need to reinvent this wheel
someone else already made a templating
language that gives me this
functionality so I'm gonna combine our
works into one and I didn't call it a
language a moment ago because frankly
HTML CSS Python JavaScript I mean we're
already like running out of fingers here
but Jinja is indeed yet another language
it's just not a programming language per
se though it will have some control flow
features that we'll see in a little bit
it's just much more limited than Python
other questions good question could you
combine the success and the fail your
pages into one short answer yes and let
me not show it yet because it'll get a
little more complicated but yes I could
imagine passing a variable in that's a
boolean true or false into just one of
these templates and maybe I call the new
template result dot HTML I can actually
then have an if condition in my template
that says if the result is true say this
else if the result is false say this
other thing so you could do that yes
generally though it's probably cleaner
to keep messaging separates if they
functionally do something else after all
these files are pretty small anyway
yeah just for question what does the
user see on if they were to take a well
open up the you know the debugging
console on Chrome
look at and see what do they see and the
tech is the HTML that shows up really
good question what does the user see we
can answer this by just literally
opening Chrome and opening the view page
source or the inspector this is what the
browser sees so when Iced claimed
earlier that the browser has no idea
Python or flask or even involved that is
indeed true because what the browser is
receiving at the end of the day is just
this that dynamically constructed HTML
good question yeah good question we'll
see more of this in just a little bit
the question is can you between the
curly brace and percent signs put actual
Python code you can put stuff that looks
like Python code but not all of Python
and so more on that in the bit only
certain functions templating languages
long story short our sandbox so that
they are not as expressive as a real
programming language otherwise you are
vulnerable to potential hacks you want
their functionality to be very limited
because they're only about displaying
data not about thinking or doing logic
generally more on that in a bit all
right that was a lot all at once in the
sake of 5 minute break here turnarounds
music come back and we'll make this app
better all right we are back so to recap
we're frosh I am off we now have this
structure which is pretty much
conventional any web application we make
here on out is going to follow this
pattern of having an application PI
entry point where all the interesting
stuff starts and layout on HTML file in
your templates directory that lays out
the whole site in any commonalities and
then one or more other pages that
actually represent your individual views
that correspond to one or more of your
actual routes so now we're at the point
of like a stable baseline but have we
dived in right to this I would perhaps
not make as much sense as to why we did
this various factorization so let's now
improve this because of course if you
look at success H tml it just claims you
are registered well not really because
in application PI did we do anything
with the users information no we just
checked did they give us information and
if so we claim success else if they miss
their name and/or their dorm we just
claimed failure so where what would
might a data structure be in Python
where we could store registrants we
don't have databases yet we don't have
sequel yet that's a
ahead yeah we could use an array
otherwise known as a list in Python so
let me propose how we might do this let
me actually open up frosh IMS one for
our second iteration of this program and
in application PI notice this at the
very top of the file not only am i
creating my application using the same
line as before and I've commented things
this time in advance using the hash
symbol notice that I claimed that on
line six and seven here here is an empty
list for all of the students who have
registered this way we can keep the
information around and we only did this
briefly last time but does anyone
remember how you add something to a list
in Python via what function append yeah
so if you have dot append at the end of
a lists name you can add something to it
so where is that going to go well here
is my route for slash which implies
again get by default that's the default
route that a human might get and they
are gonna see index dot HTML which
contains that form if I scroll down now
you'll see that I have a register route
just like before but I'm doing one
additional step which is the new line
here to be clear yeah 26 so I could
implement this in any number of ways but
the key detail is that I reference the
list name students but I could have
called it anything dot append as someone
proposed is how you add something to the
end of the list and then I can add
anything I want to keep it simple I'm
just gonna add a string and I'm gonna
keep it super simple and just say the
string is so-and-so from such-and-such a
dorm so David from Matthews Hall or
Brian from wherever and so here we have
placeholders using F strings in Python
so this has nothing to do with flask
that has nothing to do with Jinja or
anything we just talked about this has
to do everything with last week's syntax
in Python alone so this appends to that
list this name from this dorm
so let's go ahead now and try this
version out if I go into my source 7
directory for today's code into frosh
IMS one and run flask run will see a URL
that I can now visit let me go ahead and
open that for frosh IMS 1 notice that I
have that complete drop down now let me
go ahead and say David but I'm not gonna
tell you my dorm yet and try to register
now I see a more friendly message not
just failure and that's because of my
new and improved temp
okay I'll go ahead and be David and I'll
be from Matthews here let me go ahead
and register and voila now we see David
from Matthews has registered and it
seems to be all of a sudden in the form
of a new bulleted list but where did
that actually come from well I don't
know let me try this again let me go
back to slash which is the route that
gives me the form let me go ahead and
type in not David this time but say
Brian and Brian which dorm are you in
Pennypacker so let me choose this from
the menu instead and click register and
now we see Brian from Pennypacker so
somehow the application is changing
State and notice the URL that we're at
is called slash registrants okay so that
seems to be a third route this time that
apparently is not interactive per se it
just spits out the list of registered
students so let's just put the
proverbial engineering hat on if we go
about implementing this slash
registrants route logically what must
that code be doing in super bowl
pseudocode if you will like a for loop
iterating over what yeah over the list
of students which contains all of those
registrants and the template meanwhile
probably has like an li tag for list
item and a UL tag for unordered list
which gives me the bulleted list so
let's take a look at that so how do we
follow these breadcrumbs well if I
scroll up in application dot pi will see
a route called slash registrants and
you'll see that all it does apparently
is it returns a template called
registered dot HTML where registered
HTML is probably a template that's
generating that list but there's
something different this time I'm
passing in an argument and we saw this
earlier when I wanted to pass a name
equals David or name equals Brian I just
grabbed that from a variable this time
I'm not doing request args I'm not doing
request form because what is students
where did this come from that's the list
from higher-up recall that we have this
global variable at the top of the
program students which is initialized to
an empty list but recall that we keep
appending to it in my register route so
I can go ahead and say you know what go
ahead and pass into register HTML a
template or rather a list called
students whose value is exactly that and
again it's stupid-looking that you have
the
word on the left and the right of the
variable name you could do this
differently you again you could say foo
you could say X or Y or anything but
frankly it tends to make Samoans just
pass in the same name as the variable
that you care about so that the template
can see exactly that so what's the next
breadcrumb if I want to understand
exactly what is happening what file
should I open up next perhaps probably
registered HTML so let's go in there
it's in my templates directory by
definition and you'll see indeed a
failure message which allows me to error
check index which contains the form
layout which contains the overall
structure and finally registered dot
HTML and now we can answer the question
that you asked earlier about Python code
in the template so this one looks more
advanced than before but notice it
follows a pattern registered HTML
extends that same layout so it borrows
from that same mold so it looks the same
the body of this page though is just
this snippet of HTML
give me an unordered list open and
closed and this is what you can do now
with Jinja again it's almost identical
to Python so you don't have to worry
about thinking about learning yet
another language it's just a subset of
Python essentially so if I want to
output in list of all of the students I
use my ginger syntax here my template
syntax with curly brace % and I say for
student in students just like in Python
that induces an iteration over that list
and then what do I want to output well
we can borrow our curly braces from our
name example and just do list item plug
in the name of the student close list
item and then end for so this is the one
stupid thing with the templates whereas
in Python proper recall that you can
just say for student in students you
have a colon and then indentation
handles everything the problem with that
in the world of HTML is that browsers
recall ignore all whitespace like white
space has no special significance but in
Python it does so the way people solve
this is you literally if a little weird
lease a end for one word no space and
that's it an indentation helps you read
something like this so what is the HTML
I'm getting back I can actually look at
this let me go ahead and view page
source in Chrome and you'll see it's not
quite as pretty as might be ideal
because there's a lot of white space
which comes from those templates from my
having pretty printed those as well but
this is syntactically correct
and I'm dynamically outputting this part
inside of this layout any questions then
on this good question let's kill flask
with ctrl C let's rerun the server and
let me go back to my registrants route
and reload and sadly yes this is not the
best way to register students first
sport because if the server ever goes
offline loses power you hit ctrl C you
obviously indeed lose everyone and
notice - even though we've generally
frowned upon using global variables
which this students list indeed is why
did I define it up here in line 7 and
not for instance in my register route
here because indeed I'm appending to the
list here but I very deliberately did
not declare the list there yeah I'm
using it elsewhere in my other routes
the registrants route and also even more
to the point if I declared a list here
it becomes by definition a local
variable which means as soon as this
function exits now I've just thrown away
those students who register immediately
not even after a ctrl C so this was a
better approach to do it but it's not
what I did way back in my day I actually
did something that was a little fancier
so at the time I didn't really know at
least in what 1997 anything about
databases I don't think I even knew
about CSV files just yet or at least how
to create them dynamically so I instead
took this approach let me go into frosh
IMS - dot HTM stew and it has noticed
the same templates as before and indeed
I pretty much copied and pasted for this
second example but in application PI
notice this fanciness so here I have
almost the same thing up top in terms of
flask but I'm also using this OS library
more on that in a bit
but what about line 2 it's subtle I
rattled this acronym off I think just
once weeks ago
SMTP does anyone know what that stands
for yeah Simple Mail Transfer Protocol
email that is soap icon comes with
built-in functionality via which you can
send emails and this is exactly what I
did when I first made this website
didn't know anything about databases I
didn't know anything about saving things
to files just yet I was still learning
but I did real
hmm I could use programming to send an
email to the proctor or the RA who was
overseeing the sports program so that
they could just like save it in a folder
and know who had registered it's not
super user friendly but it at least got
the job done because they were then able
to track everything so in this program
notice that I have my route for my forum
and I have this register route but a few
new lines of code and you would only
know how to do this by reading the
documentation but in this case here
notice what I'm doing in my register
route I'm first getting the user's name
and their email this time and their dorm
then I'm error checking if they didn't
give me a name or their email or the
dorm render failure dot HTML to apprise
them as much then go ahead and do these
lines of code and this is more of a
mouthful and you would only again know
this from the documentation but it turns
out if you read the documentation for
this SMTP Lib or library you can use
lines of code like this too as follows
you can tell the library what server to
use for sending email and it turns out
if you read emails documentation you can
use SMTP Gmail comm to automatically
send emails not using the web UI but
using code 587 is the TCP port that they
use so it's not 80 it's not 443 its 587
by convention start TLS if you read the
documentation says turn on encryption so
the email is encrypted between you and
Gmail then go ahead and log in with a
certain username and password I created
an account in advance called Jay Harvard
at cs50.net and my password is in my IDs
environment I stored it elsewhere so
that it's not visible on screen
otherwise people could send emails as
John then I go ahead and call literally
a function called send mail and if you
read the documentation this one takes as
argument who you want to send email to
the contents of the email that you want
to send and the message that you
actually want to send here or rather
this is the from address the to address
and the actual message that you want to
send after that you just go ahead and
render template and assume success I
could add more error checking like I
should probably check if anything went
wrong here but I'm keeping it simple but
these new lines that are highlighted
actually send an email so let's try this
let me go into frosh IMS too and let me
go ahead and do flask run let me go
ahead and open up the page here
/and notice I do indeed have a second
field for text now so this will be David
and this will be let's see how about
let's go ahead and just register not
myself since it's not my email account
but John Harvard who we claims email is
cs50 dotnet J Harvard they're at and he
lives in say weld let's go ahead and
click register alright it's taking a
little longer this time but it was doing
a little more work sending an email so
now let's try to go to Gmail comm open
this up in my inbox you are registered
if I open this up notice J Harvard at
cs50.net has sent me an email by a BCC
to at least keep part of the information
private and it just says in the subject
in the body of the message if I move the
cursor you are registered so I did a
little more back in 1997 but I included
like the user's name and their email
address and their dorm and maybe their
phone number or whatnot and the sports
they were interested in but the idea is
exactly that you can send any
information you want just by now using
code you could not do that with HTML or
with CSS alone any questions then on
this yeah okay that was all in
JavaScript so that illusion to if name
equals and then you assigned it to a
function I think you're referring to our
JavaScript examples now okay so we'll
actually come back to that in a little
bit where we reintroduce a bit of
JavaScript which actually gives us some
more functionality reminiscent of those
examples other questions yeah it's a
really good question so via what email
address did I send that and to whom was
it sent so again this is the from
address this is the to address and this
is now the message and just because I
only have one email account open I had
John sent himself an email in this case
theoretically if I were running the
freshman intramural sports program I
could try to do this and change this
from address to be myself the catch is
that Gmail actually has protections in
place so that if you've logged in as J
Harvard with his password then the email
no matter what you specify as the from
address is actually going to be
overridden to be from John Harvard
however this does speak to the potential
insecurities of email if you don't use
Gmail but you use a third-party service
that is not so rigorous with its error
checking it is incredibly easy to fake
emails from one person to another I mean
look through your spam folder sometime
most of those people who sent you those
spams don't exist like the email
addresses and/or the names are fake and
yet they might appear to actually be
from a sibling of your as a family
member or a friend even though those
humans did not send the emails and
that's because some spammer has written
code like this in Python or some other
language but has overridden these fields
but used a server that's not Gmail that
doesn't enforce these policies other
questions
fun fact also in 1995 I learned how to
send ie or how to change the firm
address on an email and turns out at
Harvard there's this entity called the
ad board who doesn't like doing this so
you don't do that there's a sometimes
there's human defenses in place for this
not just technological thankfully my
friend whom I faked an email from did
not work that okay all right that you
have now great power don't use it for
for evil all right so let's go ahead now
and do another example but that takes
this a further step adding finally some
persistence of information let's go
ahead into frosh IMS three now and open
up application pi so recall that we can
use CSV files comma separated value
files to create the illusion of like
spreadsheets but now we're actually
going to create them ourselves the code
for this is a little more involved and
the only thing I've changed now really
is the register method so in version one
of this code I saved it in a global list
just in memory that was not good because
it gets thrown away too easily version
two of this we just sent an email to the
proctor who runs the program that was a
little better because at least they can
then save the email version three we're
gonna use a very lightweight database
called the CSV file that saves it to my
hard drive permanently so even when the
server stops the data is still there so
in Python how does this work well notice
that I've improved my register route
this time as follows if the user did not
give me
their name or dorm then I go ahead and
render a failure that's pretty much the
same logic as before but I didn't bother
declaring the variables this time I just
called the functions directly here's a
new line of code that might be
reminiscent of some of your past file
i/o code in line 16 here I'm telling
Python to go ahead and open a file
called register dot CSV quote unquote a
so we've seen our we've seen w-4 read
and write anyone recall what a is or no
it happens to mean append which means
just add a row to the file which is nice
because if there's already students
registered when a new one registers we
just want to append to the bottom of the
file quote unquote a is supported by
Python with this open function that
gives me back a reference or like a
pointer to file even though Python does
not have pointers then this is the new
feature and here too you'd only know
this from having seen an example or you
reading the documentation you can use
the CSV library which will see as
imported up above and you can ask for a
writer a piece of code that writes outs
that is create CSV files and
specifically you want to write to this
file that library the CSV library comes
with a function called write row which
does what it says if you pass it in a
comma separated list of fields that you
want to represent your first column your
second column and your third column it
will handle the writing for you so you
don't have to get into the weeds of file
i/o like you did several problem sets
ago notice the subtlety you do need to
have these second pair of parentheses
because technically what you're giving
it is a tuple we talked very briefly
about that last week which is just like
an X comma Y pair or latitude comma
longitude same idea here first column
second column and so forth is a
so-called tuple then I close the file
then I render the template so what does
this actually do for me well let me go
into my folder frosh IMS three here and
notice register dot CSV at the moment is
empty this is a CSV file it nothing's
going on inside of that there's no one
registered yet but let me go ahead then
and go into frosh IMS three run flask
run let me go ahead and load this up and
you'll see the same kind of form but
also a new link notice that no one's
registered yet if I click on that link
but if I go into here and register David
from Matthews and click register
now it claims I am registered really let
me click this link and notice that if
it's very small on the screen but slash
registered is where this is gonna lead
me which is just where I was before you
see that now David from Matthews is
registered let me go back to the form
itself let's register say Brian from
Pennypacker click register
he too is apparently registered let's
click that link Brian from Pennypacker
alright so where is this data going let
me go back to the IDE close my
registered CSV file because it's
probably changed and opened it up and
wallah indeed it's prompting me to
reload it there is the file and notice
brought David comma Matthews Brian comma
Pennypacker all of those rows were
written out for me so now I actually
have a database and even though it's
kind of a simple database you know what
I can do let me go ahead and right-click
or control-click on it in the IDE
download it into my downloads folder and
then if I actually open this thing if I
have Excel installed or Apple numbers
which is the first time I've ever used
it let me go ahead and open that file
opening registered CSV and voila here
now is a file and numbers is formatting
it in kind of a funky way but it is
showing rows and columns those of you
who are more familiar with Excel we can
do that too let me go down here let me
go into my downloads folder ctrl click
or right click here and this time open
it with Microsoft Excel and if you've
seen Excel before we'll probably see a
very similar UI because anytime Excel or
numbers say ok first time I've used
Excel so that too would open up some
rows and columns as well so CSV files
are just very lightweight spreadsheets
but what's cool about them is that you
can create them so easily you just have
to put commas in there now as an aside
can you contrive a users input that
could potentially break a CSV file
what could a human type in that could
potentially break your own CSV files a
comma right if it's like David Malan
comma jr. or something like that or
anything with weird punctuation this is
why you use libraries that CSV library
in this code which were importing at the
very top of this version 3 of the code
is actually handling all of that
complexity for us when the library
encounters David Malin comma jr. if
that's the users input
it will then additionally put quotes
around my whole name thereby making sure
that my comma is inside quotes and not
therefore confused with the special
comma that demarcates the start of other
columns so again that's why you don't
reinvent the wheel because corner cases
like that arise
well what about slash registered which
is this list that's generating an
unordered list let's see how that works
if I scroll down to this code notice
that it's not just a simple matter of
grabbing a global variable because there
is no global variable anymore now I have
to read it from that CSV file so here's
three new lines of code that work as
follows I'm gonna go ahead and open this
file register dot CSV in read mode this
time not append I'm gonna go ahead now
and say hey Python use the CSV reader
which is the opposite of writer on that
file and then hey python go ahead and
turn that whole reader into a list so
you don't really know this from reading
the documentation it turns out this is
the recommendation if you want to take a
reader and just read the whole thing
into memory at once and convert it to a
Python list you literally just pass it
to this list function that gives me a
list I'm gonna call students and then I
can do my same code as before for good
measure I should probably do what I did
last time which is file dot close to
close the file as well just to make sure
it's closed the next time it's opened
but I can actually simplify this and
you'll see more of these examples online
it's actually more conventional in
Python not to do this but instead to
change your code as follows to not
bother closing and explicitly to instead
use a keyword called width to instead
put the variable name back there and
indent everything underneath doesn't
matter for our purposes which one you do
the first one was correct the second one
is correct this is just more
conventional if only because it handles
the closing of the file for you so if
you see this online that's all that's
happening there but it's just like in C
doing F open and F close or in this case
open and close like I had a moment ago
any questions then how would I handle
duplicates good question so having
handled duplicates here at all and David
from Matthews could register again and
again but logically what might I do well
it probably belongs here in my register
route I probably want to do more error
checking than
these two lines because what I probably
want to do to see if David from Matthews
is already registered is open the CSV
file iterate over its lines looking for
David and for Matthews on the same line
and then error show a failure to the
user if he or she is trying to register
for a second time I've not made it easy
with this code and frankly that's gonna
be so much easier next week with sequel
sequel this other language for databases
will make it easy to search data that
has already been saved CSV files do not
make this easy it's it's doable but you
have to write more lines of code so more
on that to come other questions
oh all right so let's skip ahead to one
final example frosh I am 6 which will do
something a little more for us here so
if I go ahead into frosh I am 6 notice
that if I do flask run and go back to
the website here and reload the screen
and I go ahead and give you my name but
no I'm not going to give you my dorm we
have this feature
it's ugly again but where did we see
this kind of functionality when the user
does not cooperate or how did I
implement this apparently
yeah Java Script right so it turns out
that with Python you can obviously
validate the users input on the server
by just checking what's in request ARBs
or request dot form and then yell at the
user success or failure accordingly but
you can also use JavaScript and honestly
we did this two weeks ago so we just
seem to be solving the same problems
again
so how do you think about this should I
be checking for the user's name and dorm
in JavaScript should I be checking for
the user's name in dorm on the server
where I mean mixed messages now
whatever's fastest that's a pretty good
heuristic to use like what's fastest and
you know we can make it prettier by
using bootstrap or some library to give
you like a colorful box or red error
text or something like that
so which probably is faster Python or
JavaScript JavaScript why is JavaScript
just a better faster language sagen
that's why yeah they don't have to get
into the religious debate of which
language is better or faster but where
they're running is certainly important
javascript is running recall by
definition in the browser it is sent as
JavaScript code to the browser which
then executes saat client-side python by
definition today is doing everything
server side and the indeed the browser
doesn't even know python is involved
because all it gets is the HTML code
that results so okay that seems to be an
argument for not doing all the new work
we did today with if not name if not
dorm and all that and just use
JavaScript but the problem is that if
you get a little sloppy or a little
clever and only implement your
error-checking client-side because as
you say it's faster and frankly once I
make it prettier it's just going to be
more interactive and more seamless the
problem is you can't and should not
trust users suppose that I'm a malicious
user and I just want to inject some
bogus data into your website or I want
to spam you or subscribe a thousand
freshmen who don't actually exist or
just generally like create problems for
you well you might think well that's
okay I have some defenses in place in
JavaScript code and this adversary is
gonna get very quick feedback very
pretty feedback that they've not
provided these various fields but
honestly you can't trust anything ever
coming from the human if I open up
Chrome's developer tools and I go to
this down here to the dot dot dot menu
and I go to settings and I go down here
to dupe there that's all it takes to
disable all of your hard work like he or
she can just open up their browser
Chrome or something else
turn off JavaScript so now when I
actually submit this form there's gonna
be no on submit checking no on click
handling all of that is disabled so if I
go ahead and click register I at least
still in this version of frosh IMS have
server-side checking as well so this
might feel a little frustrating but it's
kind of the reality it is perfectly fine
to use JavaScript code and use
client-side code to give the user a
better experience aka UX user experience
but you can't cut corners and not
implement the same kind of logic
server-side because you need to defend
against this otherwise bogus data is
gonna end up in your database things are
gonna go wrong never ever ever try
the user any questions can you do the
same with CSS not with CSS alone you can
use CSS to make the error messages far
prettier yes but not logically enough
with CSS alone and in fact just to give
you a sense now of how you can make
things prettier since I keep alluding to
better design skills than the ones I'm
showing here if we go to bootstrap this
very popular free and open source
library for CSS it actually has some
interactive features as well and if I go
under components in the documentation
and I scroll down and I go to forms
you'll see one notice that these forms
are already way prettier than the ones
I've been making right it's like black
text and gray text and small text it
just looks a lot nicer and cleaner but
it's relatively easy to do this and
indeed for the next problems that you'll
be welcome to copy and paste some of
this sample code in HTML use bootstrap
CSS just to make your forms prettier but
what it can really do if I go to the
submenu over here notice that there's
this validation section in bootstrap in
other libraries have this too and you'll
want to read the actual documentation
but if I just scroll down for a while
here's the sample form in bootstrap it
already looks a little prettier than
anything I've made in just raw HTML but
notice if I don't cooperate you can do
really cool validation of forms with
green and red text if the user does or
doesn't cooperate by using a mix of CSS
but with some JavaScript code and so
what bootstrap does for you is it
actually automates some of the process
of that JavaScript code that we saw two
weeks ago and just use now but it
doesn't just pop up a message for the
user it actually gives them more
immediate feedback and almost any
popular website you visit these days
gives you this more immediate proximal
input generally you don't see some
simple error message popping up even
though that's easier to do any questions
alright so where did that logic come
from so let me go into for instance my
template file now for the form in frosh
I am six again the last of these
examples and you'll notice that I did
this if I scroll through this file
you'll see the same HTML as we've been
using for some time but notice at the
bottom of the page that I draw some
inspiration from two weeks back when we
looked at HTML and CSS and JavaScript so
just as a quick refresher notice how
this is working this line of code says
in JavaScript check the document using
the query selector which lets you select
anything in the in the webpage looking
for a form when that form is submitted
call the following anonymous function if
the documents query selector finds an
input that does not have a value and I
say not because of the exclamation point
here then yell at the user with this you
must provide your name and return false
else if the user did not provide a value
for the Select menu aka the dorm go
ahead and alert them that they must
provide the dorm otherwise return true
and just to be clear and to recall from
two weeks ago why am i returning false
what does that affect tab logically yes
again what was that oh I heard a whisper
yeah
nope yeah it prevents the submission of
the form the default behavior of a form
is it wants to be submitted that's why
they exist but if you return false in
JavaScript it will short-circuit that
and prevent that default behavior
thereby stopping the user from
submitting the form at all so let's take
one step back now because there's been
there's now so much going on in this one
file alone in this sixth and final
example notice that we have application
dot pi which is the entry point the
so-called controller of this web
application it has a route which very
simply for slash looks like this when
the user gets slash this template is
simply returned what is in that index
HTML template well it contains a partial
HTML file it contains this HTML but it
does not contain the doctype the HTML
tag the head tag the body tag the title
tag and all of that
it only contains the stuff that should
go inside of the
body tag because this file is using a
bit of Jinja which is the templating
language that flask uses you can just
think of it as flask that's fine
it has uses some HTML here but it also
in the bottom of the file uses
JavaScript and so just as before when
we've looked at the source of the page
what I'm gonna see in the browser on
this forms page is no Jinja no python
nothing related to flask just a fully
formed HTML page that also now contains
some of that client-side code and so I
have this mixture now of several
different language but each of which
solves a very distinct problem
yes really good observation so a couple
weeks ago I really preached the
separation of concerns and therefore
separation of files and that's why we
introduced a dot CSS file we also
briefly showed examples of a dot JS file
the short answer is as your applications
get more complex life starts to get
messy and the team and I were actually
talking about this earlier as to how to
present some of these examples because
what you are seeing in my design
decision here is attention so that
tension here is as follows it is not
necessarily the best practice to just
have your logical JavaScript code
commingled with your HTML right it makes
it harder to collaborate with someone
else if one of you is really good at
design and wants to work on the HTML and
CSS the other person really wants to do
the JavaScript code kind of hard to do
that when they're both in the same file
so we could factor this out I could
change this line just to be super clear
to be this instead of putting my actual
code in the file I could do something
like this the source of this shall be
formed j/s and that is just the it and
then I have a separate file maybe my
colleague works in as follows but at
some point the thoughts that go through
my head are it's only like ten lines of
code and I just have to create a second
file now and that second file is gonna
be maybe in a different folder is my
template and you know it feels like this
is just over engineering a solution to
the problem however once it's twenty
lines a hundred lines off now okay now
it's feeling messy it's somewhere
there's this inflection point and this
is where reasonable people will disagree
and I might argue one way you might
argue the other way and honestly both of
us are probably right and so this just
speaks to the web's development over
time and there's fancy or frameworks now
and if we tie things earlier into the
question about cs50 beyond an
opportunity after this class that looks
more closely at web programming
there are even fancier frameworks
nowadays then flask and then bootstrap
that have tried to solve this problem
react is one of the most popular ones
developed by Facebook now open source
and used by so many people around the
world that actually addresses this issue
and it allows you to separate your HTML
from your CSS from your JavaScript in
different parts of the file but still in
the same file and that was their
particular solution and view and angular
there's so many different solutions to
these problems
fortunately once we take the training
wheels up cs50 off this is what's ahead
of you like the world is messy and the
reason there's so many darn languages
and frameworks is because people like
you have these instincts and think this
could be done better and thus do we
iterate and have new and new
technologies but this is the kind of
stuff and honestly this is the kind of
silliness that changes over time the
fundamentals of HTTP and client-side
code in JavaScript code those
fundamentals are invariant even as the
implementation details change so the
short answer is
could this be better probably could it
be much better I don't know it's really
now becomes more of a debate among
developers good question
all right so let's now use some of these
basic building blocks to make a final
set of examples that demonstrates a
feature with which most of us are pretty
familiar reminiscent of what we did two
weeks ago with Google search at the time
we searched for cats today we'll keep it
a little simpler and a little less
graphical and just search for words
because you'll recall from our speller
problem set you implemented a spell
checker with like a hundred and forty
thousand plus English words that's a
pretty juicy data set to search over and
you're probably all familiar with
autocomplete these days right there's
probably a website these days that when
you start typing it doesn't try to
finish your thought for you Google
Facebook any number of other sites so
autocomplete how does that work well let
me propose the following mental model if
you do have some data set like a big
list of words or a big list of Facebook
friends or a big list of whatever you
might store that server-side because
it's a lot a lot of data and in fact
next week you might store it in a big
database but for today we'll just store
it in a file like we did for the speller
pset but if you want to create an
interactive experience for the human
what language are you probably going to
want to use so that he or she gets
immediate feedback probably JavaScript
right that's the whole principle of
client-side code is just going to
execute faster because there's no
internet between you and the code but
with Python you have access to files and
yet with JavaScript code you have closer
access to the user so there's these
tensions so how could we go about
building a site that lets a human via
form search across that file forwards
well let's start as follows so in words
0 we have the following large which is
just a text file borrowed from the
speller problem set
forty thousand words one poor line there
and I'm not even going to double-click
and open it because it's so darn big it
will take a few seconds to open in
application dot pi we have probably the
entry point to this application and in
templates we have just three templates
this time so just when you're reading
someone else's code for the first time
where should our entry point be where
should we start looking to understand
what's going on maybe application dot pi
or honestly you know what if you want to
see what something does run it right no
harm in doing that so let's run flask
run make this a little bit bigger let me
open up the URL here open and I see a
very simple form asking me for a query
let me go ahead and search for a and
click search and after a moment okay
this is a lot of words but apparently
these are all the English words that our
dictionary knows about that start with
the letter A and if I go all the way to
the bottom you'll see it stops with AZ
whatever with no B words in fact well
let's make sure this actually works and
isn't just a trick let's search for B
words okay so that seems to work as well
and notice I brought some inspiration
from Google notice that the route I'm
using is called slash search like two
weeks ago does take a Q parameter for
query and B is whatever the human typed
in so if I want to search for Z words
enter I should hopefully get back now Z
word so now unlike two weeks ago we can
implement both the front end and the
back end for a search engine but our
search engine searching now just for
words so let's look at application dot
PI as proposed which is the entry point
and let's see how I'm doing this so this
is some code that I borrowed a little
bit from last week when we quickly
implemented the spell checker in like
what twelve or twenty lines of Python
code I'm declaring a global variable
called words and I capitalized it just
to be reminiscent of last time in the
problem set I'm using this syntax which
I alluded to earlier is just more
conventional or pythonic open the large
file in read mode and call the variable
file then here is a for loop via which
you can iterate over every line in the
file reading one at a time but recall
what is every line in this file end with
like a backslash N and we don't really
want those as part of the words right
that's not part of the English word so
our strip write strip removes any white
space from the end of the string and
that's why I needed to add that extra
line so I'm just cleaning up the file or
sashing the data as you might do with
any sort of data based application so
then I just seem to have this route that
renders the template if I look in index
dot HTML let's follow the breadcrumbs go
into index dot HTML okay not that much
going on here it looks like an HTML form
the action of which is slash search just
like Google's the method which is slash
is get just like Google's there's
nothing really private about the words
I'm searching for here so I don't care
there's some fancier features here
notice placeholder is the grayed out
text the human sees auto focus what does
this do again this is just a UI feature
better user experience yeah puts the
cursor right in the text box you've to
focus on something in a webpage means
make it like what's interacting with the
user right now and Mac OS for instance
highlights it in blue so when you first
load the page the cursor is blinking in
the choice of text boxes that you care
about most autocomplete 'off just
disables the browser's version of
autocomplete so I don't see past
searches just because the whole point
here is to implement this ourselves
ultimately and then I have my search
button this is just ginger stuff from
flask so that I have a layout file let's
follow that breadcrumb layout dot HTML
nothing really that interesting going on
there if you've ever wondered why we
have these in a lot of our demos this
cryptic looking line here just makes
websites look better on mobile devices
typically by default if you pull up your
phone and look at a website if it
doesn't have that kind of line like the
text is gonna be super tiny unless you
like pinch and zoom by using this line
and variations thereof it will increase
the default font size a bit to make it a
little more tolerable on small screen so
it's an easy win for users experience
okay I seem to have exhausted all the
interesting stuff in these templates
let's look at another and final route
here's my search row and this is pretty
pythonic this is a mouthful and we'll
we're implement it in a different way in
just a moment so I have a search route
that listens for get requests on slash
search then this crazy-looking line is
about as pythonic as code gets and I'll
explain what this is doing and why it's
sort of conventional as opposed to
straightforward at first glance and then
I render the template passing in these
words
so this one-liner on line 17 actually
has the effect of searching 140,000
words for whatever words start with
what the user typed in see this would be
a pain in the neck to do in Python you
can do it with literally one line a long
line but one line nonetheless let me
make this more clear if I were to search
for words in this data in this big file
I might do something like this words is
an empty list so this lowercase words is
all of the words that match that I want
to send back to the user so by default I
have no idea what to send back but I do
know I can do this for word in words
which is the capitalized variable the
constant up at the top that has the
whole are not even constant but the
global variable that has all of the
words from the file here's a for loop
over those I can now say something like
this if the current word starts with
whatever the user typed in well what's
the user typing in well Q equals request
args get quote unquote Q gives me the
user's name dorm or in this case Q value
for query so if the word that we're
currently iterating over starts with Q I
can go ahead and append to my woops
append to this list that word would you
say you're comfortable with these lines
here to recap give me an empty list in
which to store the search results
iterate over all possible hundred and
forty thousand plus words get and
actually this was stupid I should just
put this up here because I only need to
check for that once so store the users
input in a variable called Q for each
word among 140,000 check if it starts
with the users input a B Z whatever and
if so append it to there so let's
temporarily get rid of this and just
render the template so notice this gets
the job done but this is very C like
logic it's not wrong it's perfectly
correct but Python is a language that's
meant to be a little more human readable
and a little more elegant if a little
more non obvious so this one line does
the exact same thing using a feature
called a list comprehension which ironic
is ironic if you don't quite comprehend
how it's working but here's the variable
I want to create called words these
square brackets here say give me a list
what do you want to put in that list I
want to put a word in this list which
word do you want to put in this
list the result of inducing this loop
and then only putting in this list a
word if it starts with what the human
typed in so take some getting used to
but this is just a one-liner way a very
pythonic way of expressing those several
lines a very procedural code into a
simple one-line is it better yeah not if
you can't read it but once you get more
comfortable with Python yes it's better
because it's it's less code yeah good
question in this case of a list
comprehension you can only have one line
or one condition
you can't have multiple lines therein so
I cannot start hitting Enter and
indenting here it's just not allowed so
you would only use this I'm frankly
really pushing the limits
you should only really use this syntax
when it kind of fits on your screen or
fits on a reasonable person's screen
after that you should probably do
something a little more expressive other
questions but this is very common to see
online so any tutorials if you ever see
this kind of one-liner just try to think
about it from that approach what it is
actually doing okay so propose from a
user experience perspective how could
this program be better because this is
just our first version so what could be
better for the user than this what could
be better yeah
uh-huh
oh sure words and caps is this global
variable I defined up here that stores
all 140,000 plus words that's the really
big file called large the text file down
here I just need a local variable and if
it's more clear I could call it results
and then just say results equals results
that is the subset of words that start
with a or B or whatever the human type
then that's all good question yeah why'd
it have to change my arcs too so earlier
today when I didn't understand what was
going on you should use request argh
forget requests you should use request
dot form for post requests it's always
doc yet yes but you change what you're
getting things from in an ideal world it
would have been something oh I say what
you mean get in this sense is the verb
we humans mean go get something orgs in
this sense if they had done get there
this is problem making this up but this
is probably why they did this because
get from get seems weird
whereas get from post is less weird but
it's just they've called it args and
form instead okay
so let's actually improve this but how
what could be better for the user yeah
okay maybe searching a whole word would
be good not just the first letter what
else could we do okay we could create an
index list so maybe using a hash or some
form of inspiration from peace from our
problems that would speller and actually
use a more sophisticated data structure
to get these answers more quickly and
let me propose to the goal here is to
actually implement autocomplete and this
was not autocomplete this was like
old-school search type in a query hit
enter get a page of results what if we
want to do something more immediate so
let me actually propose this before
looking at the code let me go into words
one let me go ahead and run flask in
that directory let me go ahead and
reload the form here and now notice no
submit button because there's not gonna
be any actual submissions here but I'm
gonna go ahead and hit the letter A and
ooh that's kind of cool let me do
that goes away be there's all the B
words let me go ba words be a B words be
a BA words this is how autocomplete
works so it seems to be responding
immediately to my input so something's
happening but I'm not actually
submitting the form so I'm kind of using
it now seems client-side JavaScript to
maybe talk to the server
let's infer so here - this is should be
your instinct whenever you're trying to
understand how someone's website works
if you want to learn from it or mimic
certain fundamental functionality go
ahead and inspect the page and you don't
probably care too much about the HTML
yet where is this data coming from let
me click on the network tab which we
looked at a couple of weeks ago let me
go ahead and restart this and let me
clear this and start from the beginning
of the story let's see what happens when
I type the letter A interesting there is
a web request so if i zoom in down here
notice that my browser actually searched
for Q equals a the human's input let me
go ahead and it keep searching because
I'm using keyboard shortcuts here but
let me go ahead and click this row
notice what happened I made a request to
slash search question mark Q equals a
via get alright let's see what the
response was the response here if I view
the source or rather if I were you the
response notice what came back it looks
like my server returned to me a fragment
of HTML containing hundreds maybe
thousands of words starting with a but
notice there's no ul tag there's no head
tag no title no body it's just a partial
HTML fragment but that's interesting
because I know with Python I can do
exactly that I can generate anything I
want on the server and then maybe the
browser can just plug in those changed
results so let me go ahead and look at
the code for this page if I go now to
the browser's source code the view page
source you'll see a few new lines so to
do this easily I'm actually using
another library this one is called
jQuery this was for many years super
super popular it's kind of starting to
fall out of vogue but it's still so
powerful and so useful and it's used by
bootstrap the other CSS library we've
talked about so it's perfectly
reasonable to use it here notice how I'm
including it with a script tag and it's
hosted on a third-party website so that
I don't have to save a copy of it myself
in my own IDE then let's look at the
code I actually wrote so notice that
atop this file is not even a
full-fledged form it is just the HTML
input because I don't need a full form I
don't need an action I don't need a
method because I'm not submitting it
anywhere with the humans or cooperation
I'm gonna use my own code so in my
script tag here my JavaScript code
notice what I'm doing this is some code
from like two weeks ago I'm gonna search
the tree that represents this webpage
and indeed it is meant to be a tree
recall from that time when we looked at
an HTML page there is in memory thanks
to the browser something tree like a Dom
document object model that represents
your page using JavaScript can we change
that page after the fact so what am I
going to do I'm gonna tell the browser
whenever this input here's an event
called Anki up so whenever the field has
focus it's blue and Mac OS and the human
hits a key and then let's go and the key
goes up go ahead and call the following
anonymous function what do you want that
to do now this code is a little cryptic
but let me walk us through it because
it's only three lines this code here is
using a special feature dollar sign that
comes from this library called jQuery
more on that in a moment that library
somewhat lis somewhat confusingly named
has a function called get which has
nothing to do with Python or the one we
just talked about but this has to do
with an HTTP GET with this line of code
you can tell a browser even after a web
page has been loaded go get me this
other URL please so what URL do you want
to get go ahead and get me from the same
server /search q equals and then what is
+ mean in JavaScript if you recall
concatenation so it means just append
one string to the other so this is like
saying go ahead and get me the URL that
ends with slash search question mark q
equals a or q equals b or q equals z
whatever the human typed in just gets
slapped on to the end and then that's
where we're getting it from input dot
value is the user's input the value
thereof and then the last line and this
is perhaps the fanciest notice that i am
have an anonymous function in this
library called jQuery there
is this function called get that gets a
URL when the server responds to your
request with a virtual envelope of its
own this anonymous function gets called
and the response envelope gets handed to
you so to speak as a data argument as a
data variable then what you can you do
document the query selector ul what is
ul it's an unordered list that by
default on this page has nothing in it
but recall that what the server is
sending back is a bunch of Li tags
that's great because I want to put those
Li tags right in between here so how do
I do that I go into the so called inner
HTML of the UL tag and you might not
have seen this before but you can change
the contents of an existing tag inside
of it by using inner HTML and just plop
the data in there and so what's
happening is this let me go ahead and
open up Chrome's inspector reload the
page so it's empty let me open up
Chrome's inspector go to elements as is
the default and notice on this page
notice that ul tag is open and closed
with nothing inside of it the moment
though I search for something watch what
happens if I search for a all of a
sudden whew it blinked it's a little
small now there's a little triangle
there what's inside of it all of those
Li tags that came from the server so
with Java Script we have this amazing
power now to change what's inside of a
web page by just asking the server for
more data so if you've ever used
Facebook or you've used Google Chat or
any websites that's dynamically changing
every second every minute anytime you
get a message you can literally if you
get a little nosey open up Chrome's
inspector and watch the Dom watch this
elements tab and you'll see new stuff
popping up every time you get a message
or a chat or any other such notification
on the screen now as an aside this is a
little sloppy to be returning HTML but
let's see how it's done let me go into
application PI for words one which is
this example here and an application PI
notice what I'm doing is this rather
than return a whole page of results I'm
returning a template called search dot
HTML all of the rest of this code is
identical to before if I go into my
templates and going to search on HTML
look how terribly simple the code is on
the server if all you want to do
spit out a bunch of illicit items this
is all you need there's no template like
there's no extends layout because you're
not returning a whole webpage you're
returning a tiny tiny tiny fragment of
HTML but this is arguably a little
sloppy because there's a lot of
redundancy in what's coming back if I
look at this tag that's coming back from
the server
what is obviously redundant about all of
this information that's coming back and
if I look at the network tab you really
see it under response what's redundant
this was just because I hid some like
zoom in and zoom out so it pretended to
make multiple requests so red herring
there focus only on this part here
what's redundant about all of the data
coming back it's just saying list item
word clothes list item list item word
clothes list item I mean come on just
like use a little more efficient syntax
just separate things with commas or
something lighter weight this is sending
way many bytes I mean look there's
thousands of bytes this is kilobytes by
definition of information that we're
sending justice an Open bracket Li close
bracket again and again this is not very
efficient and so the world actually has
adopted a different approach and I'm
gonna I'll show this in words too that
actually returns something called Java
Script object notation which is a more
succinct representation of this as
follows let me go into words to run
flask in there search for the same kind
of thing and then watch what happens
over the network panel this time when I
search for a I immediately get back the
same visual result but if I look at this
search query now look what comes back I
claim that this is a much more compact
representation of the same information
it's a little annoying that there's
double quotes because those are a little
redundant but at least double quotes are
a lot more efficient than Open bracket
Li close bracket and then the opposite
at the end so this is what's called
JavaScript object notation and as this
square bracket here and thousands of
words later the square bracket on the
end implies this is a JavaScript array
that's being sent back from the server
so the only thing that's changed here is
as follows in words to this example
notice that I don't even need to return
a template anymore this code is the same
as the past two examples this is how I'm
searching 140,000 words quickly but if I
include now
a fancier function from flask called
JSON fi she's not really a word but JSON
fi that takes any data structure you
have data in like this list of words the
matches and it turns it into that
text-based representation with quotes
and commas and you don't even have to
write a template yourself and indeed I
got rid of search dot HTML the only
thing you have to do to give yourself
access to this feature is import not
just render template and request and
flask but just sound a Phi as well from
the flask library which is just one more
feature all right any questions on that
before we bring it all together with one
final example yeah can double quotes
break that good question great instincts
no because the author of JSON if I was
smart about this and if that author
notices a quote like an apostrophe or
like is something in your own name that
has a quote it will escape it in some
way usually with the backslash good
instincts but that's why you probably
wouldn't want to write this code
yourself because then you have to think
of all of those corner cases as opposed
to focusing on the parts you care about
all right so there's one final example
and it's perhaps to come full circle
here do we even need the server these
hundred and forty thousand words right
now or in a file called large my web
application loads that file into memory
and then searches it but who else could
search over a big list of files where
else could we put this logic the browser
right browser gives you JavaScript
JavaScript some language languages can
search things so let me try this instead
in our words three example here notice
that I've got one new file in advance
I took my big text file that just had
one word per line and I put it into a
standard format just because it makes my
life a little easier you'll see large J
s which is a second file this time a
JavaScript file in which I've just
declared a JavaScript array of all
hundred and forty thousand words for
better or for worse I just put them into
a slightly different format with commas
and quotes and square brackets and I
gave this whole thing a variable name
at the very top of the file now why is
this useful well if I go into index.html
notice that there is no more application
dot Pi or templates for this example
whatsoever we've gotten rid of Python
entirely I don't know if it's for the
better or worse but will now see so in
this file notice we have an input tag as
before a placeholder for all of the you
ELLs but we're also now including this
large j/s file thereby telling the
browser please download all hundred and
forty thousand words and then search
them locally how am I going to search it
locally I've essentially converted the
language I wrote in Python a bit ago
into JavaScript as follows here says the
browser go get me the input that the
user can type into this tells the
browser go ahead and listen for key up
whenever that happens please call this
function which has no name because I
want you to just call it immediately I
don't need its name this function is
defined by these several lines these
several lines have to do a bit more work
than before because before the server
was doing all the hard work sending back
all of the data and we just jammed it
into the web page but here I'm gonna
build up a list a little more manually
so I'm gonna let a variable called HTML
equals quote unquote because I want to
build up the unordered list myself then
if the human indeed type something in so
if their input is non null so if they
typed at least one character do the
following this is weird in JavaScript
but when you iterate over an array in
JavaScript use the preposition of not in
so for word of words go ahead and do the
following if the current word starts
with notice the capitalized W also
different from Python but same idea just
different spelling if the word I'm
iterating over starts with whatever the
human inputted we found a match go ahead
and append to this HTML variable Open
bracket Li close bracket concatenate the
word to it and then close bracket as
well so I'm constructing a variable in
the browser's memory containing HTML
that I want to jam into the Dom
ultimately how do I do that well at the
very last line I say to the document
select the UL tag go inside of its HTML
and change whatever's there to this
string of HTML which is presumably zero
or more Li tags now based on those
search for
results so now let me go back to words
one rather good let me go back to this
example here let me go ahead and serve
this up it's not flasks anymore so I
have to use our server from two weeks
ago
HTTP server just serve up HTML let me go
ahead and reload the screen here open up
index.html and now notice we're good to
go
what do we want to search for a ok B C
and let's open up the network tab
inspect Network let's see what happens
every time I search Z huh Y Q hey why is
there no network traffic now ok but
that's what I said but why is there no
network traffic it's not sending any
routes it's not talking to a back-end
server why because all the data I might
need is already local so mixed messages
here too which is better which is right
what's the takeaway how do you think
about this because now whereas a lot of
our programs early on the semester we're
relatively small even though they didn't
feel that way at the time now we have
even more design possibilities and the
answers are increasingly non-obvious and
this is why you as programmers will just
get more comfortable with conventions
you'll maybe practice what you've seen
preached first then you'll decide as you
might be already saying I don't like
that I'm going to do this some other way
so how do you think about which of these
several words examples is best version 0
was let the server do all the work and
just send back a full new page of
results like Google in 1999 did then
version 1 we added a bit of JavaScript
that use jQuery the library to talk to
the server using a technique called Ajax
asynchronous JavaScript and XML but that
just means go get me more data and if
we've returned Li elements then we
decided that's a little sloppy you don't
seem to send me all these useless tags
just send a comma separated list of
words that was version 2 and then this
last version gets rid of all of that and
just sends all the words to the browser
and lets it deal with it entirely
who likes which best 0 1 2 or 3 what do
you think
the JavaScript then there's the
functionality of website that's a good
trade-off so if the user turns off
JavaScript o3 okay won't offend anyone
three two and one won't work anymore
because javascript is disabled now do
you care about that
maybe not it's a small number of users
on the Internet or who were so concerned
with this that just turn off JavaScript
altogether and the reality of so many
websites just break these days without
JavaScript that might be a reasonable
cost of doing business okay
other thoughts yeah is the last version
the fastest I don't know how could we
assess that yeah I mean we could
literally measure it and honestly built
into chrome and other tabs that I've not
even clicked on are a lot of performance
tools where you can actually monitor how
long everything's taking this is called
benchmarking more generally and this is
what you did essentially in the speller
problem set even though we wrote the
code that timed everything and measured
everything to answer that question you
could just try timing every one of the
examples and then decide for yourself
which is best sure yeah charging me more
data you might be getting my slowing my
phone down
very reasonable concern let me go into
our dictionary file here and list the
size of this that large JS file is 2.2
megabytes which on mobile devices
especially in places where your signal
is slow or your bytes are expensive or
you only have intermittent access that's
kind of obnoxious to send two megabytes
to the user if you can avoid it
especially when you can send only the
subset of results a few kilobytes maybe
of matches instead so very reasonable
concern cost user experience performance
other thoughts which is better for
people on like University and corporate
campuses who had tend to have really
good internet access Sega three okay but
what if it's not a hundred forty
thousand words but it's like a billion
pictures of cats right that Google index
is right or you know hundreds or
thousands of friends and all of their
profile data right like at some point
there's this inflection point where too
much data right it's not reasonable it's
too much you don't want to just give a
copy of your corporate database to every
one of your you
just for them to search more locally so
again these are the non-obvious
questions and one of the goals of
frankly the final project if you do
something web-based or mobile base or
sea based or anything is all of these
questions now boil down to you like we
have no well-defined answers in mind as
to what your final project should do and
how it should do it best but in the
weeks ahead you'll be pre proposing some
project ideas proposing an actual
project idea and then designing and
implementing this and you too will
probably feel this tension where the
answer is not always obvious your
Teaching Fellow might not even know how
to answer your question because he or
she will have all thoughts of their own
but it's ultimately up to you and we're
now at the point of a level of like
coding maturity where we're taking the
training wheels off and more of the
decisions are now left to you let's end
here I'll stick around for one-on-one
questions and we'll see you next week
for databases